[Music]
hey what's up this is dr john delony
with the dr john delony show
today we are talking about saving
marriages
about jealous boyfriends about children
with anxiety
we're talking about road rage man so
stay with us
stay tuned hi good folks and welcome to
the dr john delony show this is a collar
driven show where we talk about your
relationships your life your mental
health your physical health your parents
your kids
your annoying neighbor some article you
read on the internets
anything and everything's fair game
we're taking your calls
i want you to call me at 1-844-693-3291
the world has gone and lost its mind
up in here up in here and people are
struggling with their mental health
divorce rates are up across the world
here in the states
people are out of work they're divided
parents are acting the
fool kids are at home i guess we're all
learning
via boxes now your bosses are nuts
generally everything's a mess and if
you're lost
paralyzed you don't know what step to
take next
i'm here for you i'm waiting for your
call i can't wait to talk to you
call me at 1-844-693-3291
you can email me at askjohn
ramseysolutions.com
follow me on the interwebs at john
delony and let's get to
the phones let's go to rebecca in
cleveland ohio
good morning rebecca how in the world
are you
i'm doing very well dr john thank you so
much for taking my call oh the pleasure
is one thousand percent mind it's so
great to talk to you how in the world
can i help
well i've got a marriage question and
which is paralyzing me
oh okay let's bring it on yeah a quick
background is i was married 30 years
my husband left me for someone else um
two years later i met a man that i
thought was a perfect partner we ended
up getting married
the first year it was a disaster it was
truly the worst year of my life
and i left um he's a controlling
narcissist
um so we divorced but since the divorce
we keep getting back together
this has been on and off for two years
now um
i take marriage and my vows very
seriously uh sometimes to my own
detriment
and so i'm really struggling with this
and my question is
how do i make a decision about whether
or not this marriage could be saved or
if it even should be saved
that's a great question so welcome me
back to
your parents okay what was your
childhood like
um only child uh overall good
relationship with my
parents very close to my dad he was a
good guy
he was a great guy your mom was awesome
she was awesome um a lot of she was an
alcoholic
so i grew up in alcohol so that created
some problems
but later on in life she was sober
and we ended up being best friends when
she passed away so that's
cool what a cool redemption story
so then take me to your first divorce
you're married 30 years you'll have kids
together
yep three kids so you build a a world
and then one day you come home tell me
about what happens there
um well it is a long story but um due to
a lot of travel
this person got involved in a lot of
infidelity in another country
so i want to back that up because the
way you said that is you blame the
the travel for the infidelity so this
this your your first husband traveled a
lot
and while he was traveling he chose to
violate your marriage covenant right
right gotcha
okay um towards the end when it all came
out we agreed to reconcile
and i actually moved to the foreign
country to be with him to start over
forgave him and about two and a half
weeks into that
he said he changed his mind and sent me
packing
huh yeah um that that was more
devastating
than even finding out about the
infidelity because we're i thought we
were all set to
you know move on to a second chapter of
our lives
had he cheated on you throughout this
30-year marriage does that something
happen there at the end did y'all just
grow apart over time
or is it something woven through the dna
of your relationship
um there were a lot of reasons
a lot of dynamics as far as how he
was as a father to one of our children
um
that created a lot of rift and we were
actually really good partners good
teammates
and when we changed our roles within the
marriage where
i gave up my career stayed home
homeschooled
and then he became the breadwinner
because i used to make more
um our roles change instead of so
instead of being teams and
partners doing everything together now
it was very much
he was working and i was the home person
taking care of all of that
and i think that contributed to this
okay and so fast forward now you are how
long
were you between marriages uh
let's see four years four years
okay did you did you date during that
time were you celibate during that time
was it just a season of loneliness and
searching and trying to figure out who
in the world you were
no i had been dating um i had wanted to
be in a relationship with someone and
actually i got to the point where i was
pretty comfortable on my own
being very independent and feeling good
but this person
just seemed like this was the one
yeah you used a word that that for
anybody who
works in in mental health counseling or
coaching is a giant
like pulsing red neon sign of danger
danger which is
he was perfect what what made him
perfect
um that we could spend
hours and hours talking
he was very active in his
church we seem to have similar values in
that regard
worked well together we ran some
ministry things at church together while
we were dating
he was a great parent so he kind of
filled that void that the other
spouse did not um we are romantically
involved i mean was he
was he a good kisser
okay okay okay
so all of these other things were good
right
so all of these other things seem to
check
loneliness boxes right um
void and affirmation boxes right
right he thought he thought it was
beautiful and complimented me and
you know thought it was the greatest
thing since sliced bread so and so then
you
you find perfection the cue the disney
music
and you run off and get married
and then what happens
kind of right from the beginning there's
also alcoholism involved
um right from the beginning the
focus was on more drinking than i ever
realized
but then also was it always there and
you were just excited about the
relationship and you
chose not to see it or did it i chose to
yeah i chose to ignore a lot of it um
but it definitely once we were actually
living together 24 hours a day and then
you can't i saw how much worse it was
gotcha okay and i thought and um
so he ends up cheating on you he ends up
beginning to slowly almost like the blob
movie
encompass and control your life is that
right
yes um so the idea at least especially
from his perspective was we're equal
partners
um everything has to be 50 50.
and uh we absolutely don't try to change
each other
um so i had a little bit of a hard time
with that because
i had come from a previous marriage
where we were
very equal partners and everything very
much a team
and so very quickly within the first few
days weeks
there was just this feeling of you know
if i wanted to do
something basically he had the veto
power because unless we agreed
both of us a hundred percent all he had
to do was say no to everything
i'd like i'd like to buy you know a
towel to hang in the kitchen
well i don't want to chase clothes
okay yeah so
what is it about this relationship how
old are you
uh 58 next week 58.
so what is it about this relationship
that you think is worth salvaging
besides the besides the vow right you
you made a vowel
what what the what is there to hold on
to
well the vowel is the big one um the
probably the
secondary would be there's always that
sliver of hope of could it be better
maybe maybe he's open
to doing this better changing behavior
so i wanna i wanna i wanna step back
thirty thousand feet
and paint a full picture of rebecca okay
as the daughter of an alcoholic mom
you have been in a peacekeeping role
you have been in a partner management
role
since you set foot on earth
right you had an extraordinary father
who helped mitigate some of that
and what a blessing that was and
probably still is
right that's probably one of the main
reasons you're able to be a great mom
and we're even having this conversation
right now
um but i want you to
watch the step back and look at the
relational dynamics that have played out
through your life which is somebody
does something they withhold from you or
they traumatize you right they go to
another country
they cheat on you they violate they kind
of rub your nose and your vows
and then they invite you out there to to
to start over and then they rub your
nose in that decision again um
and you're left trying to figure out
what you did right
and then you begin to recreate another
life again you meet the quote unquote
perfect guy
you start down this road again and you
are
you find yourself once again asking
what do i need to do in this situation
and so i want
as a peacekeeper that's the way you're
wired i want you
to let go of the fantasy he's not going
to change
he's not and i understand
the economics of being a 58 year old
woman i don't understand them right i'm
not a 58 year old woman but i understand
there is
something to be said for
just walking out the door my rent might
be hard
right eating might be hard so i don't
know your economic standing so i'm gonna
put that aside over there
and know that that's a powerful thing
for many women um
i also know that the the
devastating thought of 30 more years by
yourself
and that's a withering scary proposition
right
yes it is i want to offer you a third
option which is
you are worthy of being loved you're
worthy of
somebody telling you the freaking truth
you're worthy of not being cheated on
you're worthy of buying your own
freaking towels in your living room
in your kitchen okay
and since you were four your worthiness
has been based on making sure the people
around you are doing okay and that
they're happy
and golden and joyful and fill in the
blank
and you might have got a taste of that
in between the two
husbands we'll call them butt crack one
and butt crack two
you got you probably had some peace
there but you're also lonely right
um and here you are with yet another
decision
so i can't tell you whether to leave him
i can't tell you whether to divorce him
i can't tell you what tomorrow's gonna
look like for you i can tell you this
he's not gonna change he's gonna be the
way he's gonna be
and i can tell you that you're going to
have to make a decision between
loneliness
you're going to have to make a decision
between moving around your kids
and making them and their gran and your
grandkids your new world
or you're 58 years old i can tell on the
phone that you're fun to hang out with
i can tell on the phone that you care
about other people
you were willing to pack up and move
across the world for some knucklehead
so i know you're kind of uh a person
who's loyal
lovely fun there is some dude out there
who would love to have you by his side
who's going to treat you with respect
he's going to treat you with dignity
but here's the challenge until you stop
replaying this cycle you're going to
continue to attract people
that bring chaos into the world that
need your
peacekeeping for them to get to the next
day and so
i'm going to strongly recommend you step
back
and you may have been to counseling
before you may have sat with a
professional before
but i want you to go sit with somebody
who's going to walk you back to day one
and talk about the trauma you endured as
the daughter of an alcoholic mom
as somebody who was able to reconnect
that relationship later on in life and
you probably had to do some peacekeeping
there
probably some shoving down and some
denial and
some hey it's all okay that was the past
was just the past so that you could
um have this new relationship before
your mom passed away
and i want you to work really hard to
get to a place
where you can look in the mirror and
know that guy
totally uh your first husband totally
left you in the dirt
the second guy it's not what he what you
thought um
and that brings me to this this this
big picture um that folks often
deal with when they've been cheated on
when they're working through divorce
when they're working through oh my gosh
i'm in relationship number two number
three and that's falling apart
is you stop to lose or you start to lose
trust in you
right and that can be the most
devastating thing because you thought
you were right you thought he was
perfect you thought you'd learned all
your lessons the first time after
30 years three decades and here you are
again
you thought you knew what was next you
thought you knew what you wanted you
thought you knew this guy and oh my gosh
i don't trust myself anymore
and until you can learn to hear your
heart
and listen to it and then follow that as
opposed to
trying to make everybody else well
you're going to continue to cycle and
cycle and cycle so
man i'm going to tell you to let go of
the fantasy i'm so grateful for the call
rebecca
and we'll be thinking about you moving
forward
everybody listening i want you to hear
me and on the
the the tubes that i'm looking at the
youtubes
they told me i can't say the tubes
anymore people on the youtube channel
you are worthy of being loved you're
worthy of not being cheated on you are
worthy
of forgiveness you're worthy of
a good night's sleep thank you so much
for the call let's go right back to the
phones
um give me a call here at 844-6933
kelly's waiting to take your call and
they're blowing up let's go to james
from louisville kentucky what's up
brother james how are we doing
hey good morning dr d thanks for taking
time to take my call
man thank you so much for calling what
can i do for you
i'm i'm calling about our seven-year-old
daughter alexis
beautiful name yeah tell me about alexis
we've been told by
multiple doctors she's had separate
anxiety as well as anxiety in general
and we've read a lot of different things
but really
just need help to get to the bottom of
our anxiety and how we can help her out
some active duty military and mom is a
stay-at-home mom
and when i was or when alexis who was
one i was deployed for about a year
and moved back in with her parents while
i was fine
okay and so when did you get when did
y'all see the
symptoms of her anxiety emerge so
basically ever since she was a baby she
was very
always needed to be held wanted somebody
around all the time
um and it just kind of continued on from
there
so basically her entire life so tell me
about the stress
in your wife's life um so
stressing my wife's life i mean she's a
stay-at-home mom
has both alexis our oldest and madeline
our youngest around all the time
and we're away from family most of the
time
being stationed halfway across the
country most times so
very small support structure in person
a lot of time talking to family and
friends on the phone and things like
that but just that
interpersonal seeing somebody face to
face and having that adult interaction
back me up to when your wife finds out
she's pregnant with alexis y'all are
excited this is your first daughter and
then you get the
deployment orders walk me back to those
that that season those few months there
yeah so um actually when we found out
she was pregnant we were
um actually pretty close to all of our
uh
support structure back on the east coast
and then
about halfway through the pregnancy find
out they're
gonna transfer me to california
so completely across the country as soon
as i get out there
find out we're deploying so then we
figure out okay well what are we going
to do
what's the best way to handle this and
that's when we made the decision um it's
better for her to
go back to go back home and be close to
her parents my parents
all of her sisters for that support
structure
gotcha and so then you're overseas were
you in
active combat i no i was in uh kandahar
okay um so then you come back and your
daughter's how old too
yes he was um she turned two about a
month after i got home
so you get back to california did your
wife then turn on and fly back to
move halfway across the country back to
or all the way across the country to see
you guys again or do you move to new
jersey what's what's your
what's your re-entry like so i came back
to uh pennsylvania that's where
she was staying i was gone we spent
about
30 days there where we
picked up the family and drove back
across country
to uh get back to our life in california
okay so pay me a picture of your
daughter's five
and you got a new little one in the
house what's a what's a outburst what's
an anxiety outburst that you experienced
with her when she was five she was six
she was seven
walk me through something um so
now a lot of her things always needs to
be in control
if somebody else is trying to say oh we
need to do this
no i no i want to do it this way i want
to do it this way
um so that is our biggest thing right
now is like
she's very bossy with her little sister
um you know when if we tell
madeleine hey we need you to do this
alexis will turn around and echo the
thing to tell her to do it right right
so what's uh what's a
anxiety freak out look like just an
absolute barn burn
she starts screaming no no no i hate
this
i can't do this we're not doing it no
just
completely shuts down um how do you guys
respond to the time
so a lot of the time like we'll see it
coming so we'll
take a step back and um we have a couple
different things that we've done
for like [ __ ] calm down box um
okay alexis let's take a break for a
minute go go to
wherever you choose in the house um sit
down
relax we're gonna come back to this in a
few minutes
um but when it gets to the screaming and
i hate this and
everything um it usually turns into
okay go sit down in a room quietly for
a few minutes and gather your thoughts
um
and then we we re-engage after a few
minutes of
trying to get her to settle down and uh
settling down too because
it's pretty stressful on everybody right
okay so here's a couple things i want to
talk through in general abroad and you
may have heard this stuff um
have you all seen different
psychologists medical doctors counselors
all that y'all been through
all down all those roads yes okay
uh is she on medication or anything
right now
oh no no medication okay so um you may
have heard some of this some of this may
be new
um there's several things at play here
number one um they've gone all the way
back and done studies that show
this sort of disruption and disconnected
disconnection happens in utero
meaning that babies who are not yet born
begin showing signs
of anxious depression adhd
of what i would call disconnection they
start showing that in utero
due to maternal stress and so you know
your wife
she's probably awesome
and her having this close family system
in new jersey
and then suddenly getting packed up and
moved across the country
while she's pregnant then her husband
gets shipped across the country
and we don't know what's going to happen
and is it this or is it that
and then she packs up and moves so
that's just show that's just
me hearing as an outsider in five
minutes
there's a lot of stress going on right
there and sometimes
babies are used as numbing devices
in that in that type of transition or
they are used
um they are they are can be pushed aside
in
close proximity right so they can be
present but absent meaning
they can be sitting right there on the
couch but a mom is thumbing through her
phone
um a mom is talking to other people a
mom is on her computer
and the kid is right there in physical
proximity they're
but they're not connected right they're
communicating but not connecting is the
way i like to say that
and so what a kid will start to do in
really short order
is they sense that kids co-regulate
themselves till they're about 12 or 13
and i think it actually goes to about 25
or 30.
um they are only who they are
in relationship to the people around
them particularly their mom and their
dad
and when they sense any sort of gulf any
sort of disconnection
they backfill that with this is my fault
and i've got to do something to fix it
and that's where you see young children
uh begin to rewire towards adhd or to
anxiety or to ocd
you named you nailed it it's a control
mechanism right
i'm trying they are doing whatever they
can in their tiny little five
six seven year old um power to
re-bridge that gulf and that can be
expressed in power that can be telling
their you know their brother and sister
what to be doing they can tell you guys
what to do right
um and so
i when i when i'm talking to moms and
dads here what i always want to back up
and do a couple of things number one
let folks know that your daughter needs
to know that her feelings are okay
the way she expresses them is not right
and it is okay for her to feel scared
and it is okay for her to feel like she
is losing control of the situation
and the sooner she can learn to
articulate that without it becoming a
hurricane
or just a blizzard diarrhea storm all
over the house
then you can get into controlling the
behavior part does that make sense
it does so and kind of that
makes sense too because at school and
everybody um
they all say oh she's great she always
listens she doesn't be supposed to
so right that outlines that too so she
is safe in those contexts right
and not in the dad's an army man safe
or not in the mom's beating her up safe
that's not what i mean by safe but i
mean relationally tethered she's got a
teacher who always shows up who is
always there who always looks from the
eye she's got her same knucklehead
friends that are always there always
engaged in whatever shenanigans are
going to be engaged in but
she can count on that and she's able to
put the control
um that control wand down right
and when she enters back into her home
space that's when
she enters back into that gulf and she
feels like i've got to keep this sucker
held together right and so what i like
to
um remind parents of is this
kids crave with every fiber of their
being they crave boundaries
desperate for boundaries and they will
bang their head and
fist and furniture up against those
boundaries to make sure they hold
school often provides that for them
church sometimes provides that for them
dance class or baseball practice those
provide those boundaries
and they are whole and they are firm
and so when she's in your house she's
going to be banging up against those
boundaries all day long right
and if she feels like that boundary is
wavering
if it's gonna fall over if she's got
somebody challenging
hey your feeling's not real um
that boom it falls the fence falls over
and that's when you get into those
stone freak outs right those i hate you
i hate everything
because that's just an like an emotional
um
volcano right and when you're a young
child you just can't rain those in
sometimes
so i want to be real careful about using
go away as a response to a child
in an anxious moment anxiety is
a disconnection disorder it's a the way
your brain copes with
being disconnected even if you're
disconnected in a crowded room
even if you're disconnected on the same
couch
so what are some things some
psychologists and counselors have told
you guys to try
uh so sometimes they say um
i mean obviously she doesn't like
surprises so um
saying hey tomorrow we're gonna do this
in a couple hours we're gonna do this
not surprising her with something new so
um planning things out
using visual charts for like a bedtime
routine
to say okay you know you need to brush
your teeth
setting those routines is one of the big
things that they have said
um will help and then also
like that um the down box is something
that when she does get into
one of those big areas just
um having some things that she can
do to uh calm down before re-engaging
in the conversation so what i wanna i
wanna recommend y'all do this
i want to recommend moving way upstream
and helping her develop control in
another way and
so i would love to have you and your
wife and her i don't know how
how young your other child is how young
madeline is but
i want you y'all to create a a set of
family values
that you co-create together and instead
of focusing so much on the behavior
you've got to get her amygdala to slow
down
and the way you do that the way a child
absorbs that
is through eye contact through touch
often
hugs um often touching
kids faces like a lot of i touch my
son's face
and my daughter's face every single day
of their life twice a day
minimum in the morning and at night um
touching their feet
and so instead of making this all a
cerebral exercise where you're focusing
a lot on the frontal lobe here's some
information here's some things that
you're doing
i want you to get to i mean you probably
learned some of this in your military
training i want you to get to
more of the fight-or-flight response way
upstream
and so the way you let her know that she
does not have to be in control
is not through more information it's
through
touch it's through you being present
it's through your wife being present
so i want you i'm gonna give you guys a
30-day challenge
in your household i want you and your
wife to make a commitment that there are
no
phones and no screens in the room when
the kids are in the room
and that might be really hard it might
be really easy i don't know the the
rhythms of your home
but i want your kids to know when
they're in the room
that they are you are present you are
listening to them you are talking to
them you are engaged with them
and they can feel you number two i want
your daughters to see
you and your wife hug i want them to
hear you say positive things lovely
things reassuring things to your wife i
want you to show up for mom
and they are going to become
increasingly
less volatile by watching a
strong anchored in relationship in their
home
right and so if you and your wife are
having marriage issues i want to
strongly encourage you guys to go get
marriage counseling on your own
and create a tree of stability instead
of a hurricane
in the middle of that living room right
and then number three again
touching their face touching their feet
eye contact
come up with a set of family values that
she gets to be a part of
and that way when she does lose it which
is going to be
fewer and fewer times is my prediction
because she she's proving she can do it
at school she's proven she can do it on
her friends so that tells me that she's
not out of control she doesn't have
you know operational defiant disorder
right she's not all over the place this
is a matter of her trying to regain
control and what she feels is an
out of control ecosystem so when she
does step out of
step out of control when that sucker
goes off right then
you can refer back and say hey you've
chosen to step outside of the
values that we all four created and so
as a part of that
it breaks my heart because i want you to
be at the table with us i want you to be
right here
but you chose to step out ah i can't i i
hurts my heart
let's go do our time in the box and then
and then as soon as you're ready to step
back in let's step back in
and what we're trying to do is show her
that she's got control way upstream
and she can just let
that control mechanism go right
let that control mechanism go childhood
anxiety is tough man because you want
the
the little girl that you love so much to
be whole
and well and it's heartbreaking it's
heartbreaking heartbreaking
james i want you to know that i'm
thinking about you
control the chaos outside of your
daughter's heart and my guess is
outside of her her need to hold on to
things
control it bring the
bring the temperature of that room down
outside of her and give her some
structure
up river and let her be a part of that
ah i'm looking forward to
hearing back call me back james i want
to hear how that goes
and that leads me to this i want to have
a quick conversation about
my brother my little brother sent me a
message the other day
and said hey will you talk about this on
the radio and this is
um he said i'm struggling with this so
little brother i'm calling you out here
i'm not gonna give your name or anything
but uh it's very similar
and it's about control and so here's
what he asked me
he asked me about road rage he asked me
about getting so mad when you're driving
and so i want to set the stage here
right you're driving down the road
somebody cuts you off
and you instantly like you flip them off
or you're one of those people who like
lay the horn on for an extended period
of time
or you're what i call an atomic idiot
where you just drive up really close and
get one inch from their bumper and you
just follow them around through traffic
if they hit the brakes you're the one
that's gonna die not them you're just
gonna rear end them but you'll show them
and it's even it's especially funny
right like in a little honda civic
and they're following up on a truck i'm
like yeah i'm gonna show you right you
yell you swear at them you you grip the
wheel real tight
how many of you have kids who have
learned brand new words
just by riding in the car with you right
and if you're in texas
or tennessee or any of these other like
people states you start thinking
somebody cuts you off
i'm like where's my gun right right and
i'm not gonna like we're not gonna take
this anymore right
the old twisted sisters song and so
here's the deal if you're driving
someone cuts you off someone takes the
shoulder in traffic someone cuts in line
when you're dropping your kids off in
school you're faced with two
important cosmic truths here they are
number one
you are not the center of the universe
right and number two
in the grand scheme of the cosmos you
are
basically in control of
nothing of almost nothing
when someone flies by you or cuts you
off or you're dropping little timmy off
at school and they get in front of you
you feel small and angry and out of
control
because hey we have order around here
and that order starts with me
and you're not being safe and i was next
and blah blah blah you feel slighted
you feel less than you feel like if you
were more of a man right or if you were
more of a woman
the world was more fair and if everyone
just played by the rules then you would
feel good about yourself
and in these little moments played out
at a hundred miles an hour on the
highway or
three miles an hour into chick-fil-a
drive-through a little piece of the
cosmos rears its head
you realize you have outsourced your
personal and spiritual validation
your worth as a person to some external
source
and you are only good in relation to how
others interact with you
this is disorienting when we realized
that we need other people to act the way
we want them to to feel good about
ourselves to feel in control
and you realize that your human default
setting is always looking for ways
people are actively screwing you over
and if you constantly look for places
where you're a victim where other people
aren't following the rules
you will always always find them
and to remedy this disorientation this
frustration
we like to get into other people's heads
and play god psychologists call this
fundamental attribution error that's
when we get in somebody else's head and
we assume why
they did what they just did right so on
the road it goes something like this
i follow the spoken and unspoken rules
of the road because i'm a good person
i'm a moral person and i'm really
intelligent
you don't you drive like an idiot you
speed and cut people off
because you're evil you're not as smart
as me and in general
you're a pile of dried goat turds right
and i want to tell you is fundamental
attribution here getting inside
somebody's head to figure out why they
do what they just did
is such a waste of energy of
time it's just a waste of brain power on
its face this remedy doesn't make us
feel better
and the truth slowly seeps in that no
matter how much you work out or not
how much you talk tough or know the law
or know how to roof a house or skin a
deer
or how nice you are or how much you give
to local charities
you are not control of hardly anything
except two things you got control two
things your thoughts
and your actions that's it david foster
wallace
spoke about this beautifully poetically
in his famous this is water speech if
you haven't heard it
google it david foster wallace this is
water i think it was at a kenyan college
graduation
he spoke about this critical idea that
we get to choose
what we think and so here's what i want
you to do
the next time you feel road rage the
next time somebody cuts you off
the next time somebody cuts in line
somebody drives too fast and is quote
unquote unsafe
i want you to choose to not feel
slighted
somebody flies by you at 100 miles an
hour and a 45
don't don't assume they're a double
cheek butt crack right
assume that they are flying to the
emergency room you get to choose that
you get to choose which one you default
to or
assume that they're flying to go pick up
their sick kid from a friend's house
and you can choose to say a quick prayer
and let it go
if somebody flips you off in traffic
you can smile and choose to just let it
go like a vapor
assume that their dad is on life support
or choose to think that
they just got a final write-up at work
and they might lose their job tomorrow
and they're on edge
and they chose you to take it out on
because you can take it
work towards making empathy your default
setting and not
righteousness not victimhood you can be
right
or you can enjoy your life man and if
you smash the windshield or grip the
wheel tight
or honk real loud or speed up on their
bumper that's like punching yourself in
the face and hoping it breaks their nose
it's just stupid at the end of the day
road rage is a waste of time it's dumb
and it solves
nothing so choose productive thoughts
practice
this then choose to keep driving
normally
and choose to keep your blood pressure
in check choose to not drive like an
idiot
choose to send positive thoughts towards
people in a hurry
they need them right so there you go
little brother there's my little rant on
road rage right
so let's get back to the phones let's
get to
monica in los angeles monica how in the
world are we doing
hi dr d thank you for taking my call
today thank you so much for calling it's
it's not even it's still the middle of
the night in los angeles right
uh no it's actually like 8 30 in the
morning right now
all right very cool say hey how can i
help
um so i i guess i
am having some difficulty between
like my mentality i i have a long term
boyfriend
and right now we're kind of like in
relationship limbo
as i would call it and i'm really
struggling between like
you said wait you said long-term
boyfriend and in relationship limbo
which one is it
um well right now we're
in relationship limbo but we had been
together for about
uh almost two and a half years okay
um but the the main issue that we've
been having is that he majority of my
friends are guys and he just
never wanted anything to do with them
and
he didn't want me he didn't trust me
hanging out with him
along without him and even if i did take
him with me
he just in a sense acted like they
didn't exist and didn't really
associate himself with them or anything
and
it's something that i've been like
continuously bringing up to him because
i
slowly detached myself from my friends
because of it
uh thinking you know he's just
insecure because in his past you know
five-year relationship his
uh ex-girlfriend left him for another
guy
and you know if i can just show him you
know i'm not her
and i'm not there to like leave him um
things will get better and so
so here's the deal they they won't
because that's not something that you
can solve monica
that's not a you can't fix him
on this one the
the decision you've got before you is
this
you've got a guy that got hurt and
that's fair right he got cheated on he
was with somebody for a long time she
broke his heart
and now he likes you and
you've got a set of friends that are a
bunch of dudes right right wrong or
indifferent
you got some friends that are a bunch of
dudes have you ever dated any of these
guys by the way
no no no are these just work buddies
college buddies like
where how do you know these dudes
uh mostly from work and then i have a
couple that i met in class
in in college okay i've never dated i've
never flirted with any of them
or anything like that so none of that
for him none of that matters
this is um an alarm system issue for him
right so this is one time
he was sitting at the front of his cave
or at the back of his cave and a tiger
showed up
and mauled him and now every time he
walks by any sort of cat shaped object
he's taken off running right
he's been down that road before and
until he does his own healing
and his own work that alarm system is
going to continue to go off
that's nothing you can do you can't um
you can't constantly be mining your day
and your life
for how he's going to respond you can be
hospitable and not a jerk
the question you're going to have to
decide is do you love him
do you want to spend the rest of your
life with him and in this current state
being with him means
that he doesn't want you hanging out
with a bunch of other guys
um or do you like these work friendships
more than you like this guy
that's the basic question because you're
not gonna be able to fix him over here
so what do you choose
monica are you there yeah i'm sorry
no that's okay it's just like i guess a
really tough pill to swallow
yeah it's hard do you love this guy
yeah i really do is he good to you
he is so what is it about these other
guys
what is it about hanging out with other
other men
what is it about them that is worth
hurting the guy that you love
oh they just they bring my friends
for like four or five years yeah
it just it sucks because that's
basically my social circle
and it's not that i haven't tried being
friends with girls it's just
all the girls that i've encountered they
have boyfriends and they
they feel like i'm there to like
try to you know do something behind
their backs with their boyfriends
or something like that and it's just i
just feel like
i i don't feel like i have the best of
luck
when it comes to like trying to be
friend girls because they always feel
like i have
like an ulterior motive in some way
shape or form
do you approach people with a flirty
energy with a sexy energy is that kind
of your thing
no no i'm literally i'm literally just
friendly you're just kind i yeah i just
asked you know how's your day
um you know you look kind of sad is
everything okay at home
um is there anything i can do to cheer
you up and that that's
pretty much it but somehow
i don't know and so i've been with the
same woman for over 20 years
and if i'm out to dinner and
she has a friend and her friend's
husband
pulls up next to my wife and says hey
you look really sad
um how are things going like everything
okay
like is there anything i can do to help
you out i'm gonna knock that dude's
teeth out the back of his head i'm
probably gonna go to jail
and then i'm gonna have to be all weird
here at work at ramsay solutions i'm
gonna have to like go to a board meeting
and explain to them why i got arrested
for punching some strange guy
in a restaurant right so here's the
thing i want to honor your heart here
right i know that i'll trust you that
you have no ultra motives you're a good
human being you're just
kind the world desperately needs more
kind people in the world right
the other side of that is man sometimes
when everyone around us is sending us
the same signal
at some point we got to go to the mirror
right we gotta go to the mirror and say
what am i contributing to my own misery
what am i
contributing to my inability to make
friends here right
and so if folks if if new girlfriend new
girlfriend afternoon girlfriend
has a weird vibe at some point you got
to get somebody that you trust whether
that's a counselor or
a mentor or somebody from your church or
somebody just in your friend's circle
and say like man tell me the truth
do i do i just weird people out do
people think i'm hitting on their
boyfriends
and you might have to make some
behavioral changes in your life if you
want to have community right if you want
to have friends
and that brings me back to the central
question that you called about is this
you cannot fix your boyfriend you can't
fix him
he has asked you to
not spend your extracurricular time
whatever time you have between work and
school
with a bunch of other guys he's asked
you for that time
it doesn't sound super unreasonable to
me
um in fact that sounds appropriate if
y'all are getting more serious you're
getting more
locked in together you're thinking about
what tomorrow might look like you're
thinking about getting married to this
do you think about having kids with this
guy
at some point you're gonna have to let
those other
like college buddy dudes you're gonna
have to let those circles
fade off into the mist man they were fun
they were exciting and now i'm
creating a world i'm co-creating this
new universe with this guy um
or you're gonna have to look in the eye
and say man you won't be a guy
that makes me give up my friends i don't
want that i want to keep hanging out
with my buddies after work
and you're gonna have to wish him well
and i know that's a hard either or
monica but
two and a half years man you know
whether you love him or not you know
they're gonna spend the rest of your
life with this dude
and you also know his pain you know his
experiences you know his hurt
and he's drawn a line for you and so i'm
gonna recommend you get with somebody
that you trust
you have a hard conversation and you
stop stringing him along you stop
stringing you along
you stop stringing you along make the
hard call dude make the hard call monica
thank you so much for the call
call me back i want to know how this
thing ends i'm going to not sleep well
for the next few weeks that's not really
true i'm going to sleep just fine but i
do want to know how this
how this wraps up all right so this has
been the dr john deloney show
thank you so much for calling i want to
leave you with the song lyrics of the
day
my good friend bobby one of his favorite
songs it's blue sky
from the allman brothers band the lyrics
are
walk along the river sweet lullaby it
keeps on flowing
and don't worry about where it's going
no don't fly mr bluebird i'm just
walking down the road
early morning sunshine tell me all i
need to know
you're my blue sky you're my sunny day
lord you know it makes me high when you
turn your love my way
the allman brothers band you know what
since it's a beautiful day out here in
nashville i'm gonna give you one more
and this is from one of the greatest
records in the history of mankind
you don't see it on a lot of top 10
lists i think it's because it transcends
top 10 list it's got into our cultural
dna and it's in our soul
and this may be one of the most
important lyrics in the history of
song really and i know that's a bold
statement but that's what we do here on
the delony show
we make bold statements it's from the
run dmc record king of rock the 1985
classic and i want you to listen to this
and i want you to put this in your soul
run suggests i'm the king of rock there
is
none higher listen sucker emcees
should call me sire to burn my kingdom
you what
you must use fire
run will not stop talking
till he retires i'm the king of rock
there is none
higher sucker mc should call me sire to
burn my kingdom you must
use fire ladies and gentlemen i don't if
i had a mic i would drop it it's on a
pole right here
i won't stop until i i won't stop
rocking until i retire either
this has been the john deloney show
thanks for hanging out with us
be kind to each other be kind to each
other tell the truth
and have an awesome week i'll see you
soon take care